so the federal government through
Congress and now signed by the president
has passed the cares Act which is
essentially a two trillion dollar
stimulus package to help borrowers of
student loans and many other aspects of
the economy to have financial relief so
let's talk about student loans and the
major impacts there are essentially five
different ways that the cares Act
impacts your student loans first there's
been a suspension of federal student
loan payments through September 30th
2020 that means that you do not have to
make any federal student loan payments
between now and September 30th 2020 the
change is automatic you don't need to
contact your student loan servicer but
again remember it's just for federal
student loans owned by the federal
government so what does that mean it'll
be your direct loans for example which
most people have but it won't include
two types of loans so FF II L loans
which were essentially issued by banks
prior to 2010 and some Perkins Loans as
well which are usually owned by
ecologist universities second there's
been a full interest waiver on all of
your federal student loans during this
time period again through September 30th
2020 that means your interest rate and
your federal student loans has been set
to 0% it's just temporary it'll set back
after September 30th back to your
original interest rate but if you do
choose to make student loan payments for
your federal loans and you can it's not
required that you suspend your student
loans you can make federal student loan
payments at that 0% interest rate and
effectively what will happen is you will
not make a lower payment you'll make the
same monthly payment you made before but
essentially the payment will be used to
first pay off any interest that's
accrued and then it will go towards
paying your principal balance so it's
actually a great time if you do have the
financial resources which many people
don't but if you do during this time
period you can actually make more
progress on student loan repayment
the third change from the cares act as
there's been a full halt of garnishment
of wages Social Security benefits and
tax refunds if your student loans are in
default this is for federal student
loans and again default means you
haven't paid your federal student loans
in at least 270 days so there's been a
full stop through September 30th at that
time it will resume and again so what
does that mean that means you do have
essentially the next five to six months
to improve your finances perhaps get out
of default and just get some extra money
together
the fourth change employers and this is
not required but it's optional employers
can pay your student loans through the
end of this year December 31st 2020 up
to five thousand two hundred and fifty
dollars and that payment for any
employee will be tax-free it's an
optional provision but it is another
student loan benefit that can take place
in the workplace and finally the last
change which has caused a lot of
confusion if you're enrolled in a
student loan forgiveness program so it
may be a public service loan forgiveness
program for example that's a federal
program for public servants and for
those who work in nonprofits or even an
income-driven repayment plan where you
can also get student loan forgiveness if
you decide to take advantage of the
payment pause through September
thirtieth and you don't make any federal
student loan payments the federal
government will still count those
payments as if you made them so for
example public service loan forgiveness
requires 120 monthly student loan
payments if you do not make your student
loan payments your federal student loan
payments during this time period you
will still get credit there's a lot of
confusion around this but but rest
assured and the cares Act you do get
better for it unfortunately if you have
private student loans many of the
benefits that are inside the cares Act
won't apply to you so if you're
struggling to pay your student loans
right now you're not sure how things
will apply to you during the coronavirus
public health emergency it's best to
contact your lender or student loan
servicer and discuss potential options
and those are the five essential main
changes there are other financial
reliefs and benefits but those are the
five you can focus on for now
you